this is a real good one too
stop taking advice
or criticism
from people
that you wouldn't trade places with
straight up somebody like you can only
take somebody as far as you've come
yourself okay
um
i've
i've been training at the dojo for
a year and a half now doing boxing
i can only train somebody else to that
level okay i could never compete in a
proper fight like i would never
challenge
um you know like a world-class fighter
to a fight that would be stupid right
but
i could train like a beginner probably
so you can only take somebody as far as
you've come yourself
now i'm close to 50 i've lived a long
life
done a lot with business
uh
been
in lots of relationships been married
been divorced i'm in a good relationship
right now
um
i can talk a lot about that stuff i can
talk a lot about business i can talk a
lot about startup i can talk a lot about
cars i can talk a lot about self-care
these you know these these are things
that i understand
so
i'm going to come back to again distill
it
never take advice from somebody that you
wouldn't trade places with
it's as simple as that i mean it's one
of the reasons why i inherently knew
growing up as a younger man i would
always lean into guys older than me i
always wanted to
be in rooms where a guy was like 20 30
years older than me
and
it was just an opportunity and i don't
want to use the term pick his brain
because that's not what i did but to
develop dialogue in a relationship and a
friendship
so that
you can
learn more about the life that they've
lived the things that they've done where
they've been and all that sort of stuff
if you know what i'm saying
so yeah don't take criticism from
anybody you wouldn't trade places with
hate always comes from beneath i've
talked about this before nobody ever
gets jealous of a loser and don't take
advice from anybody that's
a nobody or has only been as somebody
for a short period of time got to be
very careful with that
you